için hemen Açılın gençler geliyor diye
bir kitap yazdım iki yıl önce bu bir
araştırmanın sonucuydu Türkiye'nin ve
Nestle gençleri ve gelecek Şimdi buradan
size bir Ufuk turuyla dünyada Neler
Oluyor Bize Neler oluyor onu göstermek
istiyorum yaklaşık 12 milyon 15-24 yaş
grubu gencimiz var burada az olanlardan
ve toplam nüfusun yaklaşık yüzde onbeşi
dünyada 1.2 milyar bu yaş grubundan var
ve bunlar hepsi birbirine bağlı
unutmayın hem seyahat ediyorlar Hem
internet aracıyla konuşabiliyorlar ve
yüzde 16'sı toplam nüfusun 2020 mm
gelecek gelecek diye hatırlayanlar var
mı mm Geliyor geliyor çoğunuz o yıllarda
doğdunuz milenyıl geliyor Milenyum bak
geldi ve 20 yıl geçti ya
Bu yıl içinde neler oldu biraz önce üç
harika konuşma izledik ortak noktası
teknoloji ve bin insanlığa açılışı
bakınız 36 sene geçti de ve 36 sene Peki
kablo ile bağlananlar var mı
hatırlıyorlar mı internete şimdi 5G
geldik katlanarak artıyor büyük birinden
bahsediyoruz internet tavsiyeniz yan
nesnelerin internetinden bahsediyoruz
Bugün bir akıllı telefonda belki
NASA'nın geçmişteki bilgisayarı kadar
kapasite var süper bilgisayarlar Biraz
önce bahsedildi birbiriyle konuşan
birbirlerini yöneten bizlerin artık
müdahale edemeyeceğimiz bilgisayarlar
Sanayi 40 Bütün dünya buna Hazırlık
yapıyor fabrikalarda robot kullanılması
değil robotların kendi aralarında
konuşması ve insanları dışarıda
bırakması demek insanlara giderek daha
az ihtiyaç kalıyor şehirlerin
akıllanması dan bahsediyoruz kendini
yöneten şehirler ısıyı elektriği trafiği
evlerine kullanmasından bahsediyoruz sür
bu araçlar başladı Hatta biber yakında
ve iki sürücüsüz bir helikopter ve uçak
servisi yapmayı planlıyor dünyada
dronlar işte eğer Viar giyilebilir
teknolojiler bütün bunlar olurken 60'lı
yıllarda aya girmişti 2000'li yıllarda
2033 de varsa getirilmesi hedefleniyor
robotlar Geçmişte küçük kol hareketleri
yapabilirdi ve sadece elleri gidebilirdi
şimdi düşük kalkıyorlar Boston
dynamics'in videolarına bakın dünyada
gelecekte şu anda gördüğümüz bilimkurgu
filmlerindeki her şeyin çok yakında
başımıza geleceğini anlayacaksınız bir
tarafta muazzam bir teknoloji var Öbür
tarafta ise biz insanlar Biz ölümlüler
ve doğamız büyük sorunlarla karşı
karşıya savaşlar akıl almaz boyutlara
geldi ve bunun sonucunda göçler Biz bunu
çok yakından biliyoruz terör Eskiden
uzakta olurdu şimdi Londra'nın Paris'in
kalbinde oluyor
ve Avustralya koskoca bir kıta yanıyor
çevre felaketleri ve başa çıkamıyorlar
inanıyor musunuz koskoca bir kıta nasıl
Sönmez gıda güvenliği sorun ve devamlı
hibrit tohumlardan bahsediyoruz salgın
hastalıklardan bahsediyoruz brexit
siyasi belirsizlik hiç öngörülemeyen
şeyler trump'in uyanıyor acınası
değiştirdiğinde bütün dünya değişiyor ve
Bütün bunların sonucunda bizlere
etkileyen ve sizlerin geleceğini
etkileyecek en önemli şey işsizlik iş
yok artık işimiz yoksa üretemeyen ceksek
hayatı anlamlandırmaya cağız ve bu
İnsanlığın en büyük tehlikesi olarak
görünüyor ve depresyon Muazzam yaygın
her yerde dünyada ülkemizde de bir
tarafta hocalarım çok iyi bilir Sinan
hoca Kerem burada beyin projeleri
yapılıyordu bre initiative Amerika'nın
çok büyük projeleri öbür taraftan da ruh
sağlığı projeleri yapılıyor en son
gördüm Barbie'nin bir MS
bu ve meditasyon yapan Barbie modelleri
çıkmış Artık bambaşka bir dünyaya
geliyoruz Peki 2020'de dünyada geveze
nesi ne yapıyor Bizimkiler de gelmeden
Davos biliyorsunuz dünyada bütün ağır
kişilerin bulunduğu ocak ayından daha
bir ayda 17 yaşındaki Greta thunberg
herkesin ilgi odağı aydı işte yeni nesil
bu Prens Charles Gidip kendisiyle
konuşuyor yine Grammy Ödülleri vardı
Takip ettiğiniz Bilmiyorum
seviyormusunuz biri ayrı iş diye bir
genç beş tane güvenme aldı milyar
dolarlık bir ekonomi den bahsediyoruz
milyar dolarlık bir endüstriden
bahsediyoruz 18 yaşındaki Ali sakar
sun2000 30/3 Mars'a gitmeye hazırlanıyor
17 yaşında Nobel Barış Ödülü sahibi
oldum Hala daha 22 yaşında önünde
koskoca bir ömür var Bu nesilde çok da
zengin var 18 yaşındaki Eric Bitcoin
Milyoner İnik 17 yaşında yaptığı
aplikasyonu Yahu ya sattı 30 milyon
dolara Bu grupta böyle
bu milyon dolar milyar dolar bize ne
zamanında binler konuşulurdu onbinler
yüzbinler şimdi Milyonlar milyarlar den
bahsediyoruz Kardeşler ailesinin en
genci dünyanın en girişimcilerinden en
büyük girişimcilerinden biri oldu 1
milyar dolarlık serveti var biraz daha
yaşlı bu milenyıl grubunda Mars'a kırmak
bakın hayatına son derece enteresan
ailesiyle çocuklarıyla kurduğu muazzam
bir düzen var bağışlar yapıyor Daha 35
yaşında Prens Harry'nin yaptıklarını
biliyoruz Yüzyıllık geleneğe meydan
okudu meydan okuyor bu gençler yerli
suyu bilen var mı lies o dünyaya gidiyor
diyor ki herkes manken gibi olmak
zorunda değil kiloluyum güzelim gurur
duyuyorum ve kendimi seviyorum Pitbull
Ticaret belki Amerika'nın başkanı olacak
Demokrat Parti'nin ön seçimlerinde şu
anda önde giden aday 38 yaşında
Afganistan'da savaşmış 7 dil biliyor
eski belediye başkanı ve bir erkekle
bu belki Amerika'nın başkanı karşımıza
olacak izleyin hiç bundan gocunmuyorum
kimsede Özel hayatını sormuyor Çünkü
yeni dedesi ile ilgili en önemli özellik
bu YouTube rakamları açıkladı YouTube'da
en çok para kazananlar arasında çocuklar
var Ray 18 yaşında 26 milyon dolar
kazanmış Anastasya beş yaşında 18 milyon
dolar bütün bu gençlerin ortak özelliği
Özgüven cesaret büyük düşünme
girişimcilik ve teknoloji Peki
Türkiye'nin gençlerine durumda kısaca
ona bakacağım 15-24 yaş grubunda mm
gençle konuştu siyah insait büyük bir
araştırma şirketi ve 45 dakika yüz yüze
görüşüldü çok derinlikli bir araştırma
dur bu içinde çok can sıkıcı verilerde
var Ben bir genel bir şeylerden
bahsetmek istiyorum Türkiye'de şu anda
bu yaş grubunda dört gençten birisi
çalışmıyor ve okumuyor bunların büyük
bir bölümü de genç kızlarımız ile
eğitimde olanlar 100 de 50 52 gençten
birisi Okul
361 Anaokulu ve kreşler gitmemiş eğitim
hayatına niye devam etmiyorsunuz diye
soruyoruz param yok duruyor Ailem izin
vermedi Ya da çalışmak zorundayım Bu
çocuklar için bir şey yapmamız gerekiyor
Herkesin bir şey yapması gerekiyor Şu
rüç gençten birisi iş yaşamında niye
çalışmıyorsunuz diyoruz çalışmama
nedenleri iş bulamıyoruz diyorlar Bunlar
çok acıklı diploması var işi var ama
hayalindeki işi yapmıyor yüzde yetmiş
7'si yüzde 49'u Hadi gençten birisi
mevcut içinde çalışmayı düşünüyor her
gençten birisi kendisine mevcut işinde
güvende hissetmiyor bir sıkıntı var
Burada iş yaşamındaki sorunlar nedir
Diye sorduğumuzda işte ücret diyorlar
fazla mesai ediyorlar bunları dışarıda
bırakayım ama bir kaç konu çok kritik
üstlerin bana kötü davranıyor diyor
taciz var diyor uzun çalışma
saatlerinden sıkılıyorlar Bir de çok
kritik bir şey uzun mesafe
ne diyorlar Yani beni uzaktan getirme
diyorlar Bir tarafta sıkıntılar var peki
fiziksel sağlıkları nasıl çok acıklı bir
tablo var kendimi sağlıklı hissediyorum
diyor gençler ama sıklıkla başlar
ağrıyor uykuları kötü iştahları zayıf
Her üç gençten biri sigara içiyor
sigaraya başlama yaşı 16 olmuş veba gibi
bir durumdan bahsediyoruz Arkadaşlar bu
ve spor yapmıyoruz cinsellikle ilgili
Formal Eğitim almamış gençlerimiz
Kişisel bakım sorularını genellikle
şöyle soruyoruz Dün diş fırçaladığımda
Dün duş aldın mı görüyoruz üç gençten
bir tanesi dişini fırçala mı şu Şanlı
kişisel hijyen de yok psikolojik sağlık
alarm veriyor yüzde seksen ikisi
tanımadığı insanlara güvenmiyor Evcil
hayvanlarla alakası yok zaten anneler
evde evcil hayvan istemiyor hiç kimsenin
evcil hayvan yok gençlerin yarısı
kendisini iyi hissediyor sol taraftaki
çok mutluluk verici ama sağ tarafa bakın
psikolojik ve duygusal olarak yorgunum
moralim bozuk kendimi yalnız
hissediyorum öfkeliyim diyor gençler çok
çok acıklı resimler bunlar
ve bunların içinde yüzde onu kendini
mutsuz ve değersiz hissediyor etrafıma
ilgimi kaybettim diyor intihar etmeyi
düşünüyorum diyor bir peki biraz önce
baktık teknoloji kullanarak neler yapmış
gençler altı saat ekranda geçiriyoruz
cep telefonu en büyük Aşkımız olmasaydı
ne yapardık düşünemiyorum uyumadan önce
uyandığımızda ilk olarak başucumuzda
duruyor Hatta duş yaparken bile cep
telefonu yanımızda Peki ne yapıyoruz
internetten üretiyoruz çatla yaşıyoruz
WhatsApp'ta konuşuyoruz filmindiriyoruz
Müzik dinliyoruz sohbet ediyoruz
internette yaptığımız şey zaman
tüketiyoruz Biraz önce bahsedildiği en
kıymetli varlığımızı tüketiyoruz şimdi
Yapay Zeka sanal gerçeklik dedik bütün
gençlik bunu Hazırlanıyor biz sorduk
gençlere yapay zekayı sanal gerçekliği
Duydunuz mu diye üç gençten birisi
duymuş onlarında sadece 129 bilgi sahibi
yani teknoloji var En
bu fonlar en gelişmiş teknoloji var ama
teknoloji dünyasından uzasın kişisel
gelişim için gençler hiçbir şey yapmamış
kültür sanat ve ses şeyine gitmemiş
kursa gitmemiş yabancı dil bilmiyor
bakın on Genç'ten Bir tanesi Yabancı dil
biliyor Onlar da çok iyi bilmiyor
olabilirler sanat kültür kursuna gitmeyi
de pil anlamıyorlar STK larda
çalışmıyorlar yüzde iki oranında STK da
çalışma aynı araştırma yaptığımızda
gençlerde finansal okuryazarlık
araştırması da yaptık bankalararası kart
merkezi için bir küçük kitaplığa yazdım
sordu paradan da anlamıyorlar Türkiye'de
ekonomi takip etmediklerini söylüyorlar
para ile ilgili bilgileri yok finansal
konular hakkında bilgi sahibi değiliz
diyorlar bilgi sahibi diyenler de çok
iyi bilgi sahibi değil Peki nasıl
yönetecekler kendi paralarını
ailelerinin paralarını ülkenin parasını
ya da çalıştıkları kurumun parasını mı
dış dünya ile ilişki kurmuyoruz her
çocuk kendi ailesinin küçük Bal
bu içinde yaşıyor ailesine güveniyor
Ailesini çok seviyor kendi
menfaatlerinden çok ailem önemlidir
diyor aileleriyle beraber yaşıyor Peki
aileyle Ne yapıyorsunuz diye sorduk Ne
konuşuyorsunuz okul konuşuyoruz iş
konuşuyoruz Konu komşu konuşuyoruz yani
kendi baloncuğu Muzun içinde kendi
hayatımız yeniden üretiyoruz ve dedikodu
yaparak vakit geçiriyoruz şimdi bu
dijital deniyor vücudun eğitim dijital
Doğanlar nasıl vakit geçiriyor bakın
arkadaşlarla İnternette müzik dinleyerek
telefonla konuşarak AVM'ye giderek film
izleyerek biraz kitap okuyoruz diyorlar
Ne kadar okuttukları bilmiyorum
alışveriş yapıyorlar yine vakit
öldürerek geçiyor gündeme internetten
takip ediyorlar arkadaşlarından Takip
ediyorlar 161 uçağa binmemiş Yüzde
altmış ikisi trene binmemiş pasaportları
yok tatil içine tatil için yurt dışına
gidenlerin oranı sadece yüzde bir ama
çok güzel bir şey Türkiye'de yaşamaktan
memnun Bu arkadaşlar bu çok umut verici
bir şey o
bu sudan farkımız yok ya ortadan daha
iyiyiz Avrupa'dan da farkımız yok
diyorlar Bu çok iyi en azından modelleri
düzgün umutları var
Bu üzücü olan bu kendi kabuğuna çekilmiş
durumdayken ülkemizi de bir kabuğun
içine sarılmış durumdayız kim düşman
diye sorduk Amerika düşman Almanya
düşman Rusya düşman Peki kim dostumuz
Azerbaycan dostumuz Rusya dostumuz şimdi
böyle baktığımızda kendimizi yapayalnız
hissedip sadece telefonunuzun ekranında
yaşayan bireylere dönüştük bekliyor
gençler Evli Mutlu Çocuklu Demet Akalın
şarkısı gibi evlenmek çocuk sahibi olmak
istiyor 27 yaşında evli olayında şu
Ailemden bir kurtulayım diyorlar İdeal
eş yaşamı Bakın bu çok kritik olan 49
yaşında emekli olmak istiyor Çok güzel
ömür boyu çalışması gerekiyor tabi ki
ideal çalışma şekli hala Tam zamanlı
çalışayım diyor çünkü Sodexo olsun
servisim olsun Sigortam olsun annesinin
öğrettiği gibi Peki geleceğin mesleği
nedir diye sorduk Doktor mühendis kamu
dediler şimdi bir tarafta gördüğünüz ilk
neler yapıyorlar ve ideal iş Özel sektör
Burada en güzel En hoşuma giden özel
532 kendi işimi yapacağım diyor bu çok
umut verici birşey Peki ideal yönetici
nasıl olacak çalışanı dinleyecek çalışma
çalışanında sevgi dolu davranacak Adil
olacak ödüllendirecek geri bildirim
verecek bu nesile çalışmak için geri
bildirim vereceksiniz bir gün küsüyorlar
işe gelmiyorlar okula gelmiyorlar bir
mesajla aşklarını bitiriyorlar hemen
kabuklarına çekiliyorlar güzel bir şey
on gençler 8'i Vatanım için çalışırım
diyor abi onları Peki biz ne yapmalıyız
çok kullanılan bir terim var pazarlamada
change management herkes değişimi nasıl
yöneteceği ne bakıyor değişimi Biz en
iyi kim yönetir şu tarihimize bir bakın
dünyanın merkezinde Bir ülkeyiz 500 bin
yıl önce Antalya'da Karain Mağarasında
uygarlık izleri var 12 bin yıl önce
Göbeklitepe bütün tarım toplumunun
doğduğu ülke Burası Hititler Truva
burada Büyük İskender'in şu kocaman
haritaya bakın
bu provalar koskoca bir dünya arkasından
bizim atalarımız Osmanlılar bakın ne
kadar büyük bir imparatorluk hepimiz bu
ülkenin içine gelmiş durumdayız Onun
için hocamın dediği gibi çok House
yaşıyoruz birbirine hiç benzemeyen ler
Bu arada ve daha çok çok genç bir
ülkeyiz 1923'te kuruldu Doğu ile batının
arasındayız bize mide işimi hiç kimse
yapamaz bunu çok iyi bilmeliyiz
yetişkinler ne yapmalı Atatürk ne demiş
gençliği yetiştirin onlara İlim ve
İrfan'ın müspet fikirlerini veriniz
geleceğin aydınlığına onlarla
kavuşacaksınız gençleri suçlamak kolay
yetişkinlere göre düşüyor birincisi her
tarafta sistem ve artık eğitimi yani
Bilim Teknoloji Mühendislik matematik ve
sanat öğretmeliyiz gençlerimize ikincisi
üniversite diploması yetmez kısa dönemli
Sektörel eğitimlere ihtiyacımız var mı
bir tek sahibi etmeliyiz tarım alanında
Sanayi alanında bir girişimcilik
ekosistemi kurmalıyız yetişkinler artık
çalışmalı gençler için bir gelecek
kurmalı yaratıcı düşünce eğitimleri
vermeliyiz Bütün işler bilgisayarlar
tarafından yapılacaksa biz yaratıcı
olmak zorundayız ve en önemlisi
arkadaşlar duygusal zeka ve farkındalık
programlarını ihtiyacımız var Her şey
biliyoruz Ve dediğimizi bilmiyoruz
duygumuzu anlamıyoruz duyumuzu
anlamıyoruz sürekli birbirimize kavga
halindeyiz Oysa Biz bireyiz ve insanız
gençler ne yapsın yedi tane hedefim var
Birincisi kendimize güveneceğiz Özgüven
en önemli özellik her sabah dünya
yeniden kuruluyor arkadaşlar Geçmiş
geçmişte kaldı gelecek Daha gelmedi
Sadece bugüne bakacağız ve her gün
yeniden kuracağız üretken olacağız
Çalışkan olacağız Çalışmadan olmuyor
Biraz önce üç harika örnek izledik Bilim
Teknoloji ve sanata yatırım yapacağız
farklılıkları kabul edeceğiz Herkes
birbirine
bu maske takmış gibi oluyoruz birbirine
benzemeyen lerden sentez oluyor tabiat
zaten böyle çalışıyor Sinan hocam Ne
dedi tabiatta Her şey çok güzel çünkü
kendi dengesini farklılıkları yöneterek
kuruyor sorunu odaklanıyoruz habire
sorun konuşuyoruz habire birbirimiz
uçuyoruz Haydi ki çözüm odaklanmamız
lazım genç arkadaşlar Hayatı kurmak için
çözümü odaklanın ve pozitif olun ve
birlik olun bizim yapabileceğimiz tek
şey bu son sayıların Bunlar içinde ben
çektim ve metroda bir anne baba bakın
çocuklarına ne kadar aşkla bakıyorlar o
çocuk ne kadar gururlu Kimbilir hangi
fedakarlık ve o bilgisayarı aldılar ve
anlamıyorlar çocuk onları her şeyi
anlatıyor şu anne babanın yüzündeki
gülümsemeye bakın İstanbul'da bir farklı
çektim de babaya bakın Ne kadar
kendinden emin kızı teknoloji kullanıyor
bu küçük kız Kapadokya'da Bir köyde
elinde ikramlar var internete bağlı ve
bu çocuklar geliyorlar şimdi 25 yaşın
üstünde olan herkes çok yaşlı artık
aşağıdan gelenler çok farklı onlar
like atmak onları yönetmek Onlarla mutlu
olmak istiyorsak kendi üstümüze düşen
görevi yapacağız ortak özellik şu
hepimizde boğulacak Özgüven cesaret
büyük düşünme girişimcilik yapacağız iş
yok artık Kendi işimizi kuracağız ve
teknolojiyi öğrenci teknoloji öğrenmek
için de mutlaka çok iyi İngilizce
öğreneceğiz Açılın gençler geliyor
diyorum Hepinize çok teşekkür ediyorum